after nearly a decade United Airlines
decided it was time for a change and
this week it updated what's known as its
livery the paint job on the outside of
the plane that comes as a growing number
of airliners are decked out in colors
meant to stand out from the rest as our
transportation correspondent Kris Van
Cleave found out airlines take their
outward appearance very seriously
sometimes spending years honing the
right look but they also can be a piece
of flying art when United Airlines
brought up the lights on its new look it
was a change years in the making and for
the plane
it took nine days to get the old paint
stripped away and the new look to come
to life thanks to 134 gallons of paint
the tail and its globe now boasts three
shades of blue the name United got
bigger and bolder the Gold Line along
the bottom is out and it's in with the
new blue swoop it symbolizes who we are
about connecting people and uniting the
world United CEO Oscar muñoz we are a
much more energetic and exciting airline
than we were a few years ago so
everything we've done symbolizes
something about the spirit of United
they were trying to create when United
and continental merged in 2010 they kept
the United name and the Continental
paint job it was the fastest way to get
all the planes to say United but the
look dates back to 1991 though it did
come with its own theme song
[Music]
airlines want to stand out in a crowd
this is why they invest time and money
to make their planes look good industry
analyst Henry Hart de belt attended the
unveiling
he points out airlines have been at the
forefront of design with their memorable
logos and looks for decades think Pan Am
or TWA
logos that live on long after the
airlines it matters more to the airline
than and to its employees than the
traveler travelers tend to pick an
airline for more pragmatic reasons
on-time performance destination price an
airline wants to look good they want you
to feel good about what you're buying
for airlines their livery is a
globe-trotting billboard usually for
themselves but sometimes for a movie or
even Hello Kitty but it can also be a
flying canvas rising like a Renoir
against the sky pieces of airborne art
painstakingly hand-painted by a dozen or
more people after Southwest became the
number one carrier in Louisiana this 737
spent nearly 12 days and 1,900 man hours
being turned into a flying state flag
its Pelican has a wingspan of 82 feet
Louisiana one is the 12th Southwest
State themed plane american wanted to
recognize its roots painting a plane in
the colors of every airline that came
together to make the world's largest
carrier 1 737 will carry the airline's
old tri-bar look others include icons of
the past
TWA US Air and America West keeping
those old looks flying also protects
Americans copyright on those brands but
perhaps the Picasso of plane painting is
JetBlue they have nearly a dozen
different tail fin designs and 17 planes
of sporting unique looks from sports
teams to blueprints it is art in the sky
it's art on the ground it brings a lot
of joy to our customers and to our crew
members VP of Marketing Elizabeth
Windham is kind of JetBlue's patron of
the Arts so you have to paint a plane
anyway you might as well do something
really fun with it
that brings a little bit of joy people
don't want to take a flight they want to
fly when the airline decided to fly to
Palm Springs they wanted to go retro but
JetBlue isn't even 20 yet
so they couldn't just van go back in
time a lot of airlines have retro jets
we aren't able to have a retro jet and
we said sure we can if we use our
imagination so we had to sort of reverse
engineer and imagine what JetBlue would
have looked like if we had been around
in the 1960s United's new look will roll
out over the next several years the cost
of paint a plane varies by size but can
top a hundred thousand dollars and once
you paint the plane you better like it
because that paint jobs gonna be around
for at least seven years for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave Reagan
National Airport
I still remember in the 70s when Braniff
had Alexander Calder the artist design
all the art in this planes they call
them flying colors and it made them
stand out I remember the PSA smile front
I loved it